it is complete chaos in Russia right now
massive protests have erupted all over
Russia after Vlad announced a mandatory
draft arseness have set fire to military
draft centers officers have been
attacked with at least one being shot
and the Russian police are showing no
mercy protesters are being beamed and
dragged off over 2 000 people have been
arrested and now Russians are trying to
escape the country as fast as possible
flights from Moscow to Istanbul or Dubai
reached as high as nine thousand dollars
for a one-way economy ticket border
crossings to Finland and Georgia are
backed up for miles with cars subscribe
to find out what happens next